- Okay, it is fully on fire (chuckles).
(happy light music)
(lighter flint strikes)
(laughs)
- All right, hold on, I need
to come up with a game plan.
- I'm gonna go ahead and say
I use all of these items.
- All right, I feel like all of these now
are meant to make me think I need them,
and I don't need them.
- I was just gonna say
I could just drink it,
but it is, I haven't
even had breakfast yet.
- Am I allowed to make this evaporate?
Does that count?
- I was gonna put all
the toothpicks on here and maybe
that would create a barrier,
but I don't think there's enough.
- I don't think this is gonna do anything.
(girl in white shirt chuckles)
- (sigh) I don't know (laughs).
- It's impossible.
Wait, is it impossible?
- This doesn't make any sense.
- This looks like it's gonna work.
(laughs) Not at all.
- Uhm, up!
Nope.
- Ah.
- Oh.
- Oh shit, it is on fire.
(blows)
- Don't quite know what to do next.
- I don't wanna light anything,
I think this is a really bad idea.
- I really don't know how to
do this, and it makes me mad.
- I think I'm done.
- [Man In Background]
You gotta blow this up.
(blows)
- Yeah, I mean, that didn't do anything.
(light happy harmonica music)
- You wanna try it?
- You light it on fire?
- Yeah.
- I'm not gonna burn myself?
(lighter flint strikes)
- Son of a bitch.
- Ah, it's hot.
It's really hot!
- [Man In Background] Go for it.
(woman laughs)
(man screams)
- It's so weird (laughs).
- Holy shit!
- Oh, it's hot.
Oh, perfect (chuckles).
(woman screams)
This is like fire cupping, you know that,
like Michael Phelps did that
last year at the Olympics?
(loud plop)
- I have a trick now.
- Yeah.
- Science is crazy, Bill Nye was right.
(loud whooshing)